we're learning more today about a stark
warning to a Colorado charter school
months before this week's deadly
shooting the two students accused of
opening fire in Tuesday's attack 18 year
old Devon Erickson and 16 year old Alec
McKenney are due back in court later
today to face formal charges the school
received a letter back in December
warning about violence and bullying at
that school David Beck knows at the
campus in Highlands Ranch it's just
outside Denver David good morning to you
good morning here's what happened five
months before the shooting at stem
school that left one student dead and
eight others injured a woman called the
school district headquarters said she
wanted to remain anonymous and she made
some explosive claims among them that
there's an extremely high drug culture
at the school that many students are
suicidal and that she was worried of a
repeat of a Columbine style massacre
here at stem she went on to say that
children are being taught to build bombs
that the school is abusing children by
making them handle feces with their bare
hands and the woman said the school was
not only tolerating drug use but drug
trafficking at the school alright here's
what happened call comes in to the
district the district writes a letter to
the school the school denies the
allegations in a lawsuit that they file
they're suing the anonymous caller
asking the judge to force the phone
company to reveal who the caller is I
tried to reach the school couldn't tried
to reach the district official who
initially took the anonymous call
couldn't reach that official either I
did confirm with the Sheriff's
Department that the school district
filed a police report based on these
allegations and there is an open
investigation right now into those
allegations later today the two suspects
in the stem high school shooting are
going to go before a judge and we will
find out whether or not the district
attorney is going to charge that
juvenile suspect as an adult
maybe beg now thank you David